Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Once there was darkness and then there was light. Once human beings lived in a state of superstition and savagery, enslaved by magic and the doctrines of the Catholic Church. And then, beginning in the salons of 18th century France, a group of thinkers in wigs led them out into the light of reason, science, revolution,
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。如果您想获得每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收看系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。曾经世界上一片黑暗，随后迎来了光明。曾几何时，人类生活在迷信和野蛮的状态中，被魔法和天主教教义所奴役。然后，从 18 世纪法国的沙龙开始，一群戴着假发的思想家带领人类走进了理性、科学、革命的光芒之中，
and the guillotine. That's the traditional... That's the... Dominic! That's the traditional explanation of the Enlightenment. Anyway, and I'm joined by my very own Jean-Jacques Rousseau, a man of chilly, cerebral faith. Tom Holland. Tom, was that a fair description of the Enlightenment, do you think? Well, you could almost have been describing the Protestant Reformation, of course.
还有断头台。那是传统的……那是……多米尼克！那是对启蒙运动的传统解释。不管怎样，和我在一起的是我专属的让-雅克·卢梭，一个有着冷酷、理智信仰的人，汤姆·霍兰。汤姆，你觉得这是对启蒙运动的公正描述吗？嗯，你刚才的描述几乎可以用来形容宗教改革，当然。
I could, yes. Well, we'll go on to say, won't we, whether they are different or not. Well, yes. I mean, I know that I'm kind of nervous about what I'm about to say, because I know that certain listeners to the podcast have begun a drinking game in which huge amounts of alcohol have to be drunk if I mention Christianity. Essentially, the mythology of the Enlightenment is that it's an emancipation, not just from the Catholic Church, but from Christianity and religion, full stop. Yes. out that your description of the Enlightenment could equally have applied to the Protestant Reformation, and indeed with certain kind of provisos with how Christianity saw itself against the context of pre-Christian paganism, is that I think that the Enlightenment is best understood as one of the great mutational processes in the history of Christian Europe. Western thought, Tom. I mean, it's bigger than just Christian Europe, isn't it?
我可以，是的。好吧，我们接下来会讨论，它们是否不同，对吧？好吧，是的。我的意思是，我知道我对自己即将要说的话有点紧张，因为我知道播客的一些忠实听众已经开始了一个饮酒游戏，只要我提到基督教，就必须喝大量的酒。本质上，启蒙运动的神话在于，它是一种解放，不仅解放于天主教教会，而且解放于基督教和宗教本身。是的。指出你对启蒙运动的描述同样可以适用于宗教改革，并且确实，在基督教如何看待自身与前基督教异教背景的关系方面有一些限定条件，我认为，启蒙运动最好被理解为基督教欧洲历史上的一次伟大突变过程。西方思想，汤姆。我的意思是，它的范围不仅仅是基督教欧洲，对吧？
Well, I'm not sure about that. I mean, so what Christians do is to say that there was darkness and then there was light. The people who walked in darkness have seen a great light. Yeah. And the darkness is equated with with with paganism what the protestants do is to is to equate the darkness with you know the romish church popery and reformation is about bringing people into light it's about toppling superstition it's about banishing idols what the enlightenment does is to is to cast the
嗯，这一点我不太确定。我的意思是，基督徒所做的事情是说，曾经有过黑暗，后来有了光明。黑暗中行走的人看到了大光。是的。而黑暗被等同于异教，新教徒所做的则是把黑暗等同于罗马教会、教皇制，而宗教改革就是把人们带入光明，它是关于推翻迷信，驱逐偶像，而启蒙运动所做的是把
whole sweep of christian history as the darkness and to essentially identify philosophy as the it's not you i see you waving at me i am because i'm conscious that some people won't know what the enlightenment was so i think you should you are the master of this you should give a 90 second overview of the dates some of the characters um what are we talking about here because the people you know even at the time they use the word enlightened a lot um this 18th century but there's never really been an agreed definition of where it where it happened or indeed when it happened no so it's incredibly difficult uh but one of the things about the enlightenment that does set it apart say say, from the Reformation,
整个基督教历史的宏大进程都归为黑暗，并从本质上将哲学确定为——不是你，我看到你在向我挥手。是的，因为我意识到有些人可能不知道启蒙运动是什么，所以我觉得你应该——你是这方面的专家，你应该用 90 秒的时间大致介绍一下时间、一些人物，呃，我们在这里究竟在谈论什么？因为人们，甚至在当时，他们也经常使用“开明”这个词，也就是这个 18 世纪，但是对于它在哪里发生，或者究竟在什么时候发生，从来没有一个真正达成共识的定义。不，所以这极其困难。呃，但启蒙运动的一个特点确实使它区别于，比如说，宗教改革，
is that there were people living through it who identified it. The name the Enlightenment comes from the 18th century. Yes. And it's such a kind of mythologized period because essentially for lots of people today the enlightenment stands as the kind of fountainhead of their sense of their identity so the enlightenment is often equated with kind of good things that liberal people feel about themselves yeah the enlightenment values i am a defender of enlightenment values it's generally it's yeah it's the sort of thing colonists say yes absolutely i think
那就是有亲历这一时期的人意识到了它的存在。“启蒙运动”这个名字就源于 18 世纪。是的。而且这是一个被高度神话化的时期，因为本质上，对当今的许多人来说，启蒙运动构成了他们身份认同感的源泉，所以启蒙运动经常与自由主义者对自己的那种美好感觉划上等号，是的，启蒙运动的价值观，我是启蒙运动价值观的捍卫者，这通常是——是的，殖民者会说的那种话，是的，绝对的，我认为
that to see the enlightenment to equate the enlightenment as it existed in the late 17th early and 18th century with you know modernity with the fruits of liberal secular democracy as we have it now is is simply wrong because i think it's much more complicated than that and the complexity of it is what makes it so slippery a subject to define well what you've done is you've very nicely you've you've you've you've basically refused to give the dates okay well i i would say that um i would date it from 1660 i i would i would identify it with spinoza do you know tom do you know the date i had i have written down in my in my notes here?
将启蒙运动——将 17 世纪末、18 世纪初存在的启蒙运动与现代性、与我们今天所拥有的自由世俗民主的果实划上等号，是完全错误的，因为我认为它要复杂得多，而它的复杂性正是让这个主题如此难以定义的原因。好吧，你刚才做的是，你非常漂亮地——你——你基本上拒绝给出具体日期。好吧，我——我会说，呃，我会把它追溯到 1660 年，我——我会把它与斯宾诺莎联系起来，你知道吗，汤姆，你知道我在笔记里写下的日期吗？
1660? 1660. But I've written it down because of the foundation of the Royal Society. Well, that shows how much more cosmopolitan I am than you. Well, why do you hate Britain? That's my question. I don't hate Britain. I love the Dutch.
1660年？1660 年。但我写下这个日期是因为皇家学会的成立。好吧，这说明我比你更有国际视野。好吧，你为什么讨厌英国？这是我的问题。我不讨厌英国。我喜欢荷兰人。
Oh, no, don't give me all that. So let's say mid to late 17th century to the, I guess, we would agree. Yeah, the French Revolution is generally taken, the advent of Napoleon. Napoleon is often described as the last enlightened despot. So, yeah, it's a sort of, it's a ferment of ideas, isn't it? And that sort of cliched description that I gave at the beginning of men in wigs and salons, I mean, that is a huge part of it. It's about clubs, coffee houses, literary salons, people like Voltaire and Diderot
哦，不，别跟我来那一套。所以，我们姑且把时间定在 17 世纪中后期到，我想，我们会达成一致。是的，法国大革命通常被视为拿破仑崛起的起点。拿破仑经常被描述为最后一个开明的专制君主。所以，是的，这是一个思想激荡的时期，对吧？而我一开始对戴假发的人和沙龙的那个陈词滥调的描述，我的意思是，那是其中的一个巨大组成部分。它是关于俱乐部、咖啡馆、文学沙龙，像伏尔泰和狄德罗这样的人
traveling across Europe, exchanging ideas, writing books, a very literate public, and this sort of sense of intellectual excitement, I suppose. Yes. I mean, and there are incredible varieties so so i think on the continent it's much more court-based yeah and i think in the netherlands and in england it's it's much more sociable but i think in both cases the the it's kind of fun i think there's with a lot of the uh the the kind of the key enlightenment thinkers you have a sense that these are people who are really enjoying themselves yeah there's a kind of sense of excitement about it and absolutely the kind of sociable quality of it
游历欧洲，交流思想，撰写书籍，有着一个极具文化素养的公众，我想，还有这种智力兴奋的感觉。是的。我的意思是，而且存在着不可思议的多样性，所以——所以我觉得在欧洲大陆，它更多地以宫廷为基础，是的，而在荷兰和英国，它要社交化得多。但我认为在这两种情况下，它——它有点有趣，我认为对于许多——呃——那种关键的启蒙思想家来说，你会有一种感觉，这些人是真的在享受其中，是的，有一种关于它的兴奋感，而且绝对是那种社交的品质，
is absolutely fundamental um and and the philosoph see themselves as so the philosoph of these french french thinkers yeah Yeah, yes. Identifying themselves with the philosophers of ancient Greece. They see themselves as, well, it's kind of a class apart. They see themselves as people leading the way into light out of darkness. And therefore, they are not in any way modest people. Well, that brings up fordex question one of our listeners and he or she um i don't know why i assume a man would call
这是绝对根本的，呃，而且 philosophe 们认为自己是——所以这些法国法国思想家的 philosophe，是的，是的。他们把自己等同于古希腊的哲学家。他们认为自己是，嗯，这是一种超然的阶层。他们认为自己是引领人们走出黑暗、走向光明的人。因此，他们绝不是谦虚的人。嗯，这就引出了福代克斯（Fordex）的问题，我们的听众之一，他或她——呃——我不知道为什么我假设一个男人会叫
himself fordex it just seems like a more stereotypically you know i imagine him as a reader of the patrick o'brien novels which you foolishly despise anyway fordex says um was it really that big a deal and was it that? That's the key question, really. So why does it matter? Why is it a big deal? I think it matters. I mean, I think it's of seismic significance and not just for Europe or for America.
自己福代克斯，这听起来更像是一个刻板印象，你知道的，我把他想象成帕特里克·奥布莱恩小说的读者，而你却愚蠢地鄙视这种小说。不管怎样，福代克斯说，呃，这真的是一件大事吗？而且它是那样的吗？这才是真正关键的问题。所以为什么这很重要？为什么这是一件大事？我认为这很重要。我的意思是，我认为它具有震撼性的意义，而且不仅对欧洲或美国而言。
I mean, I think America is, the United States is inconceivable without the Enlightenment, but because of the impact of Europe and the United States on the world, it's of global significance. And in a way, it matters because although I think it's very culturally contingent, I think it's bred very, very specifically of the particular cultural circumstances of Europe in the 17th and 18th centuries,
我的意思是，我认为美国——没有启蒙运动，美国是不可想象的，但由于欧洲和美国对世界的影响，它具有全球性的意义。在某种程度上，它之所以重要，是因为尽管我认为它在很大程度上受文化制约，我认为它是从 17 世纪和 18 世纪欧洲特定的文化环境中非常非常具体地孕育出来的，
it's brilliant at disguising itself as universal. So Voltaire, who's probably the most famous of all the Enlightenment figures, he says of the church fathers that they thought the whole world should be Christian and that therefore they were necessarily the enemies of the whole world until it was converted. And he saw himself as being superior to that. But actually, of course, Voltaire and the philosopher were doing exactly the same. And enthusiasts for Enlightenment values tend to feel exactly the same way that the entire world should be converted to Enlightenment values. But because they're able to kind of cast it as somehow universal. Voltaire talks about there being a commonality of intellectuals from Peking to Cayenne, famously. He's able to pass off this very, very kind of European, West European phenomenon as being universal. I mean, what do you think? How would you identify the Enlightenment? It's a massive question. So I think it's so there's a there's a very famous historian of it called Jonathan Israel. And he argues that it's all about ideas.
但它极其擅长把自己伪装成普世价值。因此，伏尔泰，他可能是所有启蒙运动人物中最著名的一位，他谈到教会之父时说，他们认为整个世界都应该是基督教的，因此在世界被皈依之前，他们必然是全世界的敌人。而他认为自己比那更优越。但实际上，当然，伏尔泰和哲学家们做着完全相同的事情。启蒙运动价值观的热心倡导者往往也有着完全相同的感受，即整个世界都应该皈依启蒙运动的价值观。但由于他们能够将其包装成某种普世价值。正如伏尔泰著名的言论，他谈到从北京到卡宴的知识分子有着共通性。他能够将这种非常非常欧洲的、西欧的现象当作普世价值兜售出去。我的意思是，你怎么看？你如何定义启蒙运动？这是一个巨大的问题。所以我想这是一个非常著名的历史学家，名叫乔纳森·伊斯雷尔。他认为这一切都关乎思想。
And he says it's not out of circumstances. It's the ferment of ideas. So you shouldn't – well, the social economic context have been overplayed. But I think the social economic context are massively important. So I think, you know, it's post – Europe has gone through the wars of religion after the Reformation. So there's a question from Mark Taylor. To what extent was it a reaction to the excesses of the early 17th century? I think it is a reaction.
他说这并不是源于环境。这是思想的激荡。所以你不应该——嗯，社会经济背景被夸大了。但我认为社会经济背景极其重要。所以我觉得，你知道，这是后——欧洲在宗教改革之后经历了宗教战争。所以马克·泰勒提出了一个问题。它在多大程度上是对 17 世纪早期过激行为的一种反应？我认为这是一种反应。
I think there's a huge element of that. So, I mean, we've talked before about the English Civil War, obviously Ireland, Scotland, the horrific impact of the Thirty Years' War in Central Europe. And I think you can see generally a sort of, you know, the next couple of generations are, they're not traumatised as too strong, but they're very strongly affected, influenced by that. There's a reaction against it.
我认为这里面有很大一部分因素。所以，我的意思是，我们以前讨论过英国内战，显然还有爱尔兰、苏格兰，以及三十年战争在中欧造成的恐怖影响。我认为你可以普遍看到一种——你知道，接下来的几代人，他们——说他们受创伤有点过分了，但他们受其强烈影响。这是对它的一种反弹。
But also this is an age of sort of mercantilism, trade, printing, obviously an explosion of printing. And literacy. Yeah, literacy going up. So I think something like by the end of the 18th century, about 60% of English men could read and write. I think a smaller percentage of women. So there's just far more readers and writers.
但这也是一个重商主义、贸易、印刷业的时代，显然印刷业出现了爆炸式增长。还有识字率。是的，识字率在上升。所以我想，到 18 世纪末，大约 60% 的英国男性能够识字读写。女性的比例我想稍微低一点。所以有更多的读者和作家。
And I think the other thing that we haven't, the word we haven't mentioned is science, really. And I think science, the idea of the world as a machine with laws, Kepler and his observing the kind of planetary motion. Obviously, Newton is massive. I mean, Newtonpler and his observing the kind of planetary motion. Obviously, Newton is massive. I mean, Newton is a colossal enlightenment figure, I think. Everybody had read him.
我想我们还没提到的另一件事是科学，真的。我认为科学，将世界视为一个拥有规律的机器的概念，开普勒和他对行星运动的观察。显然，牛顿至关重要。我的意思是，牛顿——开普勒和他对行星运动的观察。显然，牛顿至关重要。我的意思是，牛顿是一个庞大的启蒙运动人物，我认为。每个人都读过他的书。
Everybody knew about his ideas. And this idea that the world is a kind of watch. I read a brilliant book, actually, a few weeks ago about clocks in history. Do you see this by a guy who's the curator of the um greenwich sort of observatory and stuff and um this is the key point really when people are making clocks and they're obsessed by this idea of the world as a clock and is there a watchmaker as the watch god god is the watchmaker and you can understand how it works i think that's something all all those ideas. You know, on that topic, a brilliant thing. So Voltaire, he settles in Geneva and he also has a place at Ferny across the Swiss-French border. And in the later years of his life, he wants to plough something back in.
每个人都知道他的思想。以及世界就像一个时钟这种观念。其实我几周前读了一本非常棒的书，关于历史上的钟表。你注意到这本书了吗？作者是那个格林尼治天文台之类的馆长，然后，呃，这才是真正的关键点，当人们制造时钟时，他们痴迷于将世界视为一个时钟的观念，是否存在一个钟表匠作为钟表之神？上帝就是钟表匠，你能理解它是如何运作的，我认为所有这些观念都是如此。说到这个，有一件很棒的事。因此，伏尔泰在日内瓦定居，他在瑞士和法国边境的费尔尼也有一个住所。在他生命的晚年，他想回馈社会。
So he sponsors people in Switzerland to manufacture watches. Does he? Yeah. So he becomes a watchmaker. He becomes a... Well, he's kind of the presiding watchmaker. Where Voltaire led, Rolex followed. Yeah, where God had led.
所以他资助瑞士人制造手表。是吗？对。所以他成了一个钟表匠。他成了一个……嗯，他算是名义上的钟表匠。伏尔泰走到哪里，劳力士就跟到哪里。是的，上帝走到哪里。
Yeah, but I think the other thing that strikes me about the Enlightenment, and maybe you'll say that this is nothing new, but you get a real sense of, you could argue this is where the citizens of nowhere started. So you've got Voltaire and Diderot and all these French guys who are travelling to Russia and stuff, and actually spend a lot of their lives, Voltaire obviously, in exile. And they see themselves as part of a republic of letters.
是的，但我认为启蒙运动给我的另一个深刻印象是——也许你会说这没什么新奇的——但你会有这样一种强烈的感觉，你可以认为这就是“无根公民”开始的地方。所以你有伏尔泰、狄德罗和所有这些去俄罗斯旅行的法国人，事实上他们生命中的大部分时间，伏尔泰显然都在流放中度过。他们认为自己是共和国的一员，属于文人共和国。
They're not bound by nationality, by the nationalisms of the, not nationalism is the wrong word, but by the narrow loyalties of the past. Well, but also by religious identification. Well, I'll tell you what's really interesting. There's so much sort of swapping of identities. So Rousseau, he was a calvinist wasn't he and then he becomes a catholic converts to catholicism i think and gibbon i mean gibbon is sent to geneva i think
他们不受国籍的束缚，不受过去那种民族主义的束缚——不，民族主义这个词不对，而是不受过去那种狭隘忠诚的束缚。嗯，还有宗教身份的束缚。好吧，我告诉你真正有趣的是。有那么多身份的互换。比如卢梭，他曾经是个加尔文主义者，对吧？然后他成了天主教徒，皈依了天主教，我想；吉本——我的意思是吉本被送到日内瓦，我想
it is or certainly sent to switzerland because he has been flirting with converting to catholicism so these are people who are beginning to sort of i don't want to lapse completely into the 21st century and say their identities are fluid, but they're certainly more fluid than they would have been 100 years previously. And they see themselves as part of a cosmopolitan, they self-consciously see themselves as part of a sophisticated cosmopolitan community, don't they? I mean, I think that the 18th century is a period of massive religious ferment. you've got a kind of incredible revival process is going in the catholic church you've got methodism you've got the great awakening in evangelical process and i think that the the enlightenment is best seen as a further kind of
是的，或者肯定是被送到了瑞士，因为他曾一度倾向于皈依天主教。所以这些人开始——我不想完全退回到 21 世纪的立场去说他们的身份是流动的，但他们的身份肯定比一百年前要流动得多。他们认为自己属于一个大都会式的群体，他们是有意识地认为自己是一个精致的大都会社群的一部分，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为 18 世纪是一个宗教激荡剧烈的时期。天主教会内部正在经历一场令人难以置信的复兴进程，你有卫理公会，有福音派复兴的大觉醒运动，我认为启蒙运动最好被看作是那种震撼性的——
expression of that seismic yeah attempt to make sense of the world. And I think it does absolutely exist in the context of the traumas and the carnage and the horror of the religious wars of the 17th century. And it's often today, that process is often cast as a kind of process of discovery of toleration. I think that that mistakes it. I think that basically what people are after is to try and find a kind of um what they would call a civil religion a way of um a religious settlement that will promote kind of stability civilized living um virtuous citizenship all these kind of things. And how you get there, you know, it is contested,
试图理解世界的努力的又一种表现。我认为它绝对存在于 17 世纪宗教战争的创伤、大屠杀和恐怖的背景之中。今天人们常常将这一过程描绘为一个发现宽容的过程。我认为这是搞错了。我认为，人们基本上在追求的是试图找到一种——他们称之为公民宗教的东西，一种能够促进稳定性、文明生活、美德公民身份等诸如此类的宗教和解方案。如何达到这个目标，你知道，这是有争议的，
but it's not so contested that people are going to fight over it. And in a way that is the fact that you can travel, you know, as Voltaire does to, to Protestant, the Protestant Dutch Republic, to Protestant London, to Frederick the Great,
但它还没有争议到人们要为此大打出手的地步。在某种程度上，你可以旅行——正如伏尔泰所做的那样，去新教的荷兰共和国，去新教的伦敦，去见腓特烈大帝，
likewise Protestant Geneva. That is absolutely fundamental to Voltaire's sense of himself. Yeah, I agree with that. I think that's all true. But I think a key part of it is this idea of light and darkness. Graham Bradbeer has a question. Who decided and when that it should be given the name the Enlightenment? Now, Tom, this is mean of me because I looked this up beforehand and you didn't so yeah go on so give it to me it's a man called jubo frenchman
同样还有新教的日内瓦。这对于伏尔泰的自我认知是绝对根本的。是的，我同意这一点。我认为这些都是真的。但我认为其中一个关键部分是这种光明与黑暗的概念。格雷姆·布拉德比尔（Graham Bradbeer）有一个问题。是谁决定以及在什么时候决定应该给它起“启蒙运动”这个名字的？现在，汤姆，我这么做很卑鄙，因为我事先查过资料而你没有，所以——好吧，说吧——告诉我答案。是一个叫热博（Jubot）的法国人
who used the word lumière called talked about les lumière the lights um but actually that the idea of light and darkness i know you're going to have loads to say about this but i'll just say this you see this again and again so kant talks about emmanuel kant the great german So Kant talks about, Immanuel Kant, the great German thinker, talks about Aufklärung, kind of, I don't know, clearing of light or whatever. You see people talking again and again about light, obviously the secret society, the Illuminati, very Enlightenment group.
他使用了“lumière”这个词，谈到了 les lumière，即光明，但实际上这种光明与黑暗的概念——我知道你对此会有很多话要说，但我只想说这一点，你一次又一次地看到这一点：康德谈到伊曼纽尔·康德，这位伟大的德国思想家——所以康德谈到，伊曼纽尔·康德，这位伟大的德国思想家，谈到了 Aufklärung，某种程度上，呃，驱散光明或者诸如此类。你看到人们一遍又一遍地谈论光明，显然还有秘密结社光明会，这是一个非常具有启蒙运动色彩的团体。
But also I always think the great Enlightenment paintings are those paintings which I know you will know and lots of listeners will know by a guy called Joseph Wright of Derby. And the most famous one, Experiment on a Bird in an Air Pump, 1768. You can look it up online, an amazing painting. And people are all looking around
同时我一直认为最伟大的启蒙运动绘画，是那些我知道你和许多听众都会知道的画作，作者是一个叫约瑟夫·怀特（Joseph Wright of Derby）的人。其中最著名的一幅是《气泵中的鸟实验》（1768年）。你可以在网上查到，这是一幅惊人的画作。画中的人们都在环顾四周，
and they're surrounded by darkness and shadows. And from the experiments, there's this sort of fantastic glow of light. And that's how people thought of themselves in the 18th century. They thought what has gone before was darkness and shadow and superstition. And we are leading the 18th century. They thought what has gone before was darkness and shadow and superstition, and we are leading the world into light. And I think key to the sense
而他们四周环绕着黑暗与阴影。从实验中散发出一种奇妙的光芒。这就是 18 世纪人们对自己的看法。他们认为以前的一切都是黑暗、阴影和迷信。我们在引领 18 世纪——他们认为之前的一切都是黑暗、阴影和迷信，而我们在引领世界走向光明。我认为理解
of the Enlightenment is a sense that before that, the previous 1700 years were all about darkness and night and sort of foolishness and ignorance. Now, I'm sure you will say that that is based on a colossal and utterly misleading stereotype, won't you? No, because I think that... No. I think a sense that people are in darkness and they have to be brought into light has been a kind of abiding theme of European civilisation since the coming of Christianity.
启蒙运动的关键在于这样一种感觉：在此之前，过去的 1700 年全都是关于黑暗、黑夜、愚昧和无知的。现在，我确信你会说这是基于一种巨大且极具误导性的刻板印象，对吧？不，因为我认为……不。我认为那种认为人们身处黑暗必须被带向光明的观念，自从基督教诞生以来，一直是欧洲文明的一个常青主题。
Yeah, but they thought that people in 1200 or something were living in darkness, but you don't think they were living in darkness, do you? I mean, you're not one of these people who... Because some people say, oh, before the Enlightenment, all was medievalism and foolishness, and people lived in huts and doled themselves in mud, and they didn't care about science.
是的，但他们认为 1200 年左右的人们生活在黑暗中，但你不认为他们生活在黑暗中，对吧？我的意思是，你不是那种人——因为有些人说，哦，在启蒙运动之前，一切都是中世纪主义和愚昧，人们住在茅屋里，把泥土涂在身上，他们根本不关心科学。
And that's obviously rubbish, to my mind. I think there was lots of science. There was lots of intellectual experiments and discovery. I think there's almost nothing about the Enlightenment that doesn't have medieval roots. And I would say, you know, what I'm saying is that the very idea of worrying that people are in darkness and they need to be brought into light is absolutely constant.
在我看来，这显然是胡说八道。我认为有大量的科学。有大量的智力实验和发现。我认为启蒙运动中几乎没有什么东西是没有中世纪根源的。而且我想说，呃，我的意思是，担心人们身处黑暗需要被带向光明这种想法本身是绝对一以贯之的。
So the 12th century reformers, that's exactly what they're doing you know they it's the 12th century reformers who come up with the word modernitas the idea that uh modernity is equated with light you know this isn't something that comes that's invented in the 18th century yeah it's it it has its roots in in the process of reform in the 12th century. But they come to believe that they've invented it. And that idea has lasted. So people now, you know, you'll open the Guardian or the Times and there'll be a column saying, well, we are standing for enlightenment values against the medieval barbarism of the Taliban or whoever.
所以 12th 世纪的改革者，他们所做的正是这个，你知道，正是 12th 世纪的改革者提出了 modernitas 这个词，即现代性等同于光明的观念，你知道，这不是在 18 世纪才被发明出来的东西，是的，它——它的根源在于 12th 世纪的改革进程。但他们开始相信是他们发明了这个概念。而且这个想法一直延续至今。所以现在人们，你知道，你会翻开《卫报》或《泰晤士报》，就会有一篇专栏文章说，我们在捍卫启蒙运动的价值观，以对抗塔利班或其他什么人的中世纪野蛮行径。
So in other words, we've completely imbibed that enlightenment sense of itself. And we don't even question it now. Well, but I think that there have been three great convulsive processes where the ambition of kind of, I guess, kind of intellectual elites to reform the world has generated a revolutionary process. One of which is 11th and 12th century, where essentially you get the medieval church, the Roman church. And I would say that Catholics today still look back to that as an exemplification of darkness being banished by light. You have it with the Reformation. And I would say that believing Protestants likewise would see the Reformation as absolutely a process of enlightenment. And then you have what we call the Enlightenment. And I would say that kind of liberal, secular, atheist, agnostic, whatever, look back to the Enlightenment.
换句话说，我们完全吸收了启蒙运动对自身的这种认知。而我们现在甚至不再去质疑它了。不过，我认为曾有过三个巨大的颠覆性进程，在这些进程中，某种知识精英改造世界的野心引发了一个革命性的进程。其中之一是 11 世纪和 12 世纪，当时你基本上得到了中世纪的教会，罗马教会。我想今天的 Catholics 仍然回过头来将那视作黑暗被光明驱散的典范。你在宗教改革中也能看到这一点。我想虔诚的新教徒同样会将宗教改革视为一个绝对的启蒙进程。然后就是我们所称的启蒙运动。我想那种自由的、世俗的、无神论的、不可知论的等等人，会回过头来看待启蒙运动。
So those three processes seem to me absolutely, you know, they are obviously each one in turn is a reaction to what has gone before. But they also are obeying very, very similar and identifiable. They're repeating the formulas, basically. Yes, exactly. OK, so that raises Owen Williams's question. He says, what did the Enlightenment do for Western intellectual progress that the Renaissance didn't? And that's a really good question because I was thinking, it's only who I was thinking about, I was thinking about Shakespeare.
所以在我看来，这三个进程绝对是——你知道，它们显然每一个都是对过去的反动。但它们也在遵循着非常、非常相似且可识别的模式。它们基本上是在重复这些公式。是的，完全正确。好吧，这就引出了欧文·威廉姆斯（Owen Williams）的问题。他说，启蒙运动为西方知识进步做了文艺复兴没有做到的事情吗？这是一个非常好的问题，因为我在想，我当时想到了谁呢，我想到的是莎士比亚。
So Shakespeare is obviously a Renaissance figure, but in some ways he feels like a very kind of proto-Enlightenment figure as well, doesn't he? He's got a sense of himself clearly as part of a wider, sophisticated European orbit. He's looking back to the classical world. There's lots of stuff about kind of, you know, he's obviously thinking through things. Somebody like Hamlet is using the power of reason. So Shakespeare does seem a very proto-Enlightenment figure, even though we wouldn't put him in that. So is there a difference, Tom, between the Enlightenment and the Renaissance? And and is the enlightenment doing something different but again the renaissance is
所以莎士比亚显然是一个文艺复兴时期的人物，但在某些方面他感觉也像一个非常具有启蒙运动前身色彩的人物，不是吗？他显然觉得自己是更广泛、更精致的欧洲文明圈的一部分。他回顾古典世界。有很多关于——你知道，他显然在进行深入思考。像哈姆雷特这样的人就在运用理性的力量。所以莎士比亚确实看起来非常像一个启蒙运动的前身人物，尽管我们不会把他归入那个范畴。那么，汤姆，启蒙运动和文艺复兴之间有什么区别吗？而且启蒙运动是否在做一些不同的事情，但话说回来，文艺复兴也是
an incredibly slippery term and what we call the renaissance you know kind of whatever 15th century florence um but the the idea of looking back to the classical world and finding things there that are worthy of bringing back to life is something that's going on, you know, at least from the time of Charlemagne. And so in a sense, the Enlightenment is a process of Renaissance because you have, you know, the way in which many of the leading Enlightenment figures in their kind of ambition to shove Christianity to one side claim to be the heirs, say, of Socrates or whoever. It's another form of Renaissance. But there is, okay, I accept that this is a whole massive continuum and that we just are dividing it up slightly artificially and putting labels on it.
一个极其难以捉摸的术语，我们称之为文艺复兴的——你知道，诸如 15 世纪的佛罗伦萨——但回溯古典世界并在其中寻找值得重焕生机的事物的想法，从查理曼大帝的时代起就一直在进行。因此从某种意义上说，启蒙运动也是一个文艺复兴的过程，因为你拥有——许多启蒙运动领袖在他们将基督教推到一旁的野心勃勃的尝试中，声称自己是苏格拉底等人的继承人。这是文艺复兴的另一种形式。但确实存在——好吧，我接受这是一个巨大的连续体，而我们只是在人为地对其进行微小的划分并贴上标签。
But people at the time had a sense of ferment, didn't they? They had a sense of time, intellectual history accelerating, and a sense of ideas being swapped in a way they weren't being swapped before, and that they're living it. That's why they talk about themselves as Les Lumiere, as enlightened. It's why they're... And there's a particular kind of vocabulary, isn't there? I mean, even Edmund Burke,
但当时的人们确实有一种思想激荡的感觉，不是吗？他们有一种时代感，知识史在加速发展，而且有一种思想在以前所未有的方式进行交流的感觉，并且他们正在经历这一切。这就是为什么他们称自己为 Les Lumiere，即开明之人。这就是为什么他们——而且有一种特殊的词汇，不是吗？我的意思是，甚至埃德蒙·伯克（Edmund Burke），
who's often seen as a sort of counter-Enlightenment figure, because he's the father of conservatism, talks about when he writes to the electors of Bristol and he says, I owe you my light and judgment and my conscience. And he's using a lot of kind of Enlightenment words and reason and science. I mean, those things do make it feel different. Even just the tone and the sort of the flavour of it
他经常被视为一个反启蒙运动的人物，因为他是保守主义之父，但他给布里斯托尔选民写信时却谈到，我将我的光明、判断力和良知归功于你们。他使用了许多类似启蒙运动的词汇，比如理性和科学。我的意思是，这些东西确实让它感觉有所不同。仅仅是那种语气和那种风味
feels a little bit different than, let's say, the ferment of ideas in the early 16th century. Okay, so they're not using the word science, and certainly not in English, because the word science doesn't take on the meaning that it does until the late 19th century. And I think that there is a tendency, which is to kind of identify the sense of a war between religion and science, which emerges in the late 19th century back onto the 18th century. And undoubtedly that's the case because Voltaire again, in particular, is brilliant at picking on, say, Galileo. He enshrines Galileo as an example of an enlightened figure who is silenced by a repressive apparatus of the Catholic Church.
就感觉与，比方说 16 世纪初的思想激荡有些许不同。好吧，所以他们没有使用“科学”这个词，当然在英语中也没有，因为“科学”这个词直到 19 世纪后期才具有我们今天所知道的含义。而且我认为有一种倾向，即把一种在 19 世纪后期才出现的宗教与科学之间爆发战争的感觉，强加回溯到 18 世纪。毫无疑问确实如此，因为伏尔泰再次以其卓越的能力，特别挑出了伽利略。他将伽利略奉为被天主教教会压迫机器压制噤声的开明人物的典范。
And so this gets reconstructed in the late 19th century as an example of this kind of timeless war between religion and science. But those categories are not seen as mutually opposed in quite the same way. So there's maybe an argument that the Enlightenment has slightly been invented by Victorian writers, do you think? I think absolutely. I think our modern understanding of the 21st century is one that's been massively mediated by what's gone between the 18th century and now. Okay, that all sounds right. But reason, I mean, again, reason. So it's often, again, the Enlightenment is often described as the age of reason. Yes. But that's a very old-fashioned way of seeing it. And the relationship of the leading Enlightenment figures to reason is incredibly ambivalent and contested. So Kant's great work is the critique of pure reason.
因此，这在 19 世纪后期被重构为这种宗教与科学之间永恒战争的例证。但这些范畴在当时并不被视为以完全相同的方式互相对立。所以也许有一种观点认为，启蒙运动在某种程度上是由维多利亚时代的作家发明的，你觉得呢？我完全这么认为。我认为我们对 21 世纪的现代理解，在很大程度上是由 18 世纪到现在之间所发生的一切所调和而成的。好吧，这听起来都对。但理性，我的意思是，再次提到理性。所以启蒙运动再次经常被描述为理性时代。是的。但这是一种非常过时的看法。启蒙运动领袖与理性的关系极其矛盾且备受争议。所以康德的巨著是《纯粹理性批判》。
Hume famously says that reason is and ought only to be the slave of the passions. Well, so this raises an interesting question about the difference between continental enlightenment and, let's say, an Anglo-Saxon enlightenment. So there's always been this idea that the continental, you know, which people like me love to trade in, such a thing, is all about being sceptical and empirical and rooted in kind of common sense, Dr. Johnson kicking his rock or whatever and saying that he's therefore proved matter exists and all this sort of stuff. Do you think there is a difference?
休谟有一句名言：理性是、也只能是激情的奴隶。好吧，这就引发了一个有趣的问题：大陆启蒙运动与，比方说盎格鲁-撒克逊启蒙运动之间有什么区别？所以一直有这样一种观点认为，大陆的——你知道的，像我这样的人喜欢兜售的那种东西——全都是关于怀疑论、经验主义并植根于某种常识的，就像约翰逊博士踢他的石头或者诸如此类，并以此证明物质存在以及所有这类东西。你认为有区别吗？
Do you think that there is a kind of Anglo-Saxon exceptionalism going on and that the French are talking about one thing and we're talking about something different? So I think the fundamental division is not between, say, Britain and the continent, but between essentially Protestant countries and Catholic countries. Right.
你认为是否存在某种盎格鲁-撒克逊的例外论，法国人在谈论一回事，而我们在谈论另一回事？所以我觉得根本的分歧不在于，比方说，英国和欧洲大陆之间，而在于基本上是新教国家和天主教国家之间。对。
So I think that, say, in England, in Scotland, in the Dutch Republic, by and large, although there are exceptions, Spinoza being the most obvious, the process of enlightenment is conservative. It tends to go with the grain of the establishment. It doesn't aim to overthrow it. it um i think in france catholic country the leading figures of the of the enlightenment are much more um much more confrontational yeah the spies about so they're spiky aren't they yeah much yeah uh or diderot you know who, who kind of writes the Encyclopédie. That was most beautiful French. That was like Peter Sellers doing Anticluso.
所以我觉得，比方说在英格兰、苏格兰、荷兰共和国，大体上，尽管也有例外，斯宾诺莎就是最明显的例子，启蒙运动的过程是保守的。它倾向于顺应建制派的纹理。它的目标不是推翻它。它——呃，我觉得在法国这个天主教国家，启蒙运动的领袖们要激进得多——更具对抗性。是的，这就是为什么——所以他们很尖锐，不是吗？是的，非常——呃，或者狄德罗（Diderot），你知道，他——他编写了《百科全书》。那是非常优美的法语。那听起来就像彼得·塞勒斯（Peter Sellers）在演克卢索探长（Inspector Clouseau）。
I know. Well, I was about to pronounce it in the English way and I suddenly am slamming on the brakes. Chief Inspector Diderot. Chief Inspector Diderot. So Diderot is an overt atheist. Voltaire, I mean, vehemently detests Christianity. He famously says that if God didn't exist, we'd have to invent him.
我知道。好吧，我正打算用英语发音来念它，突然来了个紧急刹车。狄德罗总探长。狄德罗总探长。所以狄德罗是一个公开的无神论者。伏尔泰，我的意思是，强烈痛恨基督教。他有一句名言：如果上帝不存在，我们就必须创造一个。
And he expresses it in a way that you would, I'm sure, entirely approve. It would confirm your darker suspicions of the snobbery of French intellectuals. He says that he doesn't believe in Christian nonsense, but he wants his, you know, his tailor, his servants and his wife to believe in God, because otherwise he'll be cheated or cuckolded.
他表达这一点的方式，我相信你一定会完全赞同。这会证实你对法国知识分子势利眼的最阴暗的怀疑。他说他并不相信基督教的无稽之谈，但他希望他的——你知道的，他的裁缝、他的仆人和他的妻子相信上帝，否则他就会被欺骗或戴绿帽子。
That's so Virginia Woolf, isn't it? Yes. Yes. So, and of course, you know, Voltaire has this,
这太有弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）的风范了，不是吗？是的。是的。所以，当然，你知道，伏尔泰有这样一封
this famous letter that he writes in 1764, where he, he, he kind of predicts that the enlightenment, the blaze of the enlightenment will kind of create a great ferment and that the younger generations are incredibly lucky because they're going to see great things, amazing things are going to happen. And Voltaire and Diderot, we cannot help but now see them in the context of the revolution that's going to come. But that's that idea, isn't it, that they are more radical and more abstract and more idealistic and that Protestant thinkers tend to be more conservative. But for example, historians like Roy Porter say, but that's because the Enlightenment has been successful
著名的信件写于 1764 年，他在信中——他——他某种程度上预测启蒙运动、启蒙运动的烈火将创造一场伟大的思想激荡，年轻一代极其幸运，因为他们将看到伟大的事物，惊人的事情将会发生。而伏尔泰和狄德罗，我们现在情不自禁地在即将到来的革命的背景下来看待他们。但这就是那种观点，不是吗？即他们更加激进、更加抽象、更加理想主义，而新教思想家往往更加保守。但例如，像罗伊·波特（Roy Porter）这样的历史学家说，那是因为启蒙运动在，比方说英国已经成功了，它已经根深蒂固了，这种思维方式已经扎根于政治圈子、辉格党圈子之中。所以他们不需要具有对抗性。所以人们，你知道，我刚刚在试图想出——你知道的，你想到了几位伟大的人物。我的意思是，乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）、爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）、伯克（Burke）、休谟、洛克、霍布斯。你知道，这是一个很棒的英国启蒙思想家名单。
in, let's say, Britain, that it's embedded, that that kind of thinking is embedded in kind of political circles, in Whiggish circles. And so they don't have to be confrontational. So people like, you know, I was just trying to think of, you know, you think of some of the great figures. I mean, Jonathan Swift, Edward Gibbon, Burke, Hume, Locke, Hobbes. You know, there's a great list of British Enlightenment thinkers.
亚当·斯密，所有苏格兰人。好吧，你说英国。我的意思是，我认为苏格兰启蒙运动和英格兰启蒙运动非常独特。所以如果我们专门来看看——迈克尔·泰勒（Michael Taylor）的问题，他是一位伟大的历史学家，也是节目的朋友。他问，苏格兰有过启蒙运动，但英格兰有吗？好吧，苏格兰，好的——我对此有一个非常坚定的回答，汤姆。你觉得呢，约翰逊博士？
Adam Smith, all the Scottish. Well, you say British. I mean, I think the Scottish and the English Enlightenment are very distinctive. So if we just look specifically, so question from Michael Taylor, great historian, friend of the show. He asked, Scotland had an Enlightenment, but did England? Well, Scotland, okay, so I have a very firm answer to this, Tom. Do you, Dr. Johnson?
苏格兰人理所当然地对他们曾经经历过启蒙运动有着非常强烈的意识，而且完全正确，你知道，像亚当·斯密这样的人——是早期现代西方——某种文化的一些伟大思想家。他们——而且对于像苏格兰这样的小国来说，尤其是现在在 21 世纪，苏格兰正变得越来越——认为自己不同于英格兰，非常热衷于庆祝这一点，这是可以理解的。英格兰从来不谈论自己有过一场英国启蒙运动，但这并不意味着没有英国的启蒙思想家。所以当然是有的。我提到了吉本。约翰逊博士凭借他的字典、他的
Scotland, understandably, has a very strong sense of having had an Enlightenment, and absolutely rightly so you know people like adam smith um are you know some of the great thinkers of early modern modern western um sort of culture they and it's understandable that a small country like scotland especially one that's now in the 21st century that is becoming much more uh seeing itself as distinct from England, is very keen to celebrate that. England never talks about having an English Enlightenment, but that doesn't mean that there weren't English Enlightened thinkers. So of course there are. I mentioned Gibbon. Dr. Johnson is nothing if not an Enlightenment figure with his dictionary and his
俱乐部和所有这些活动，绝对是一个不折不扣的启蒙运动人物。我的意思是，我认为英格兰拥有启蒙运动是不可否认的，但由于需要抗争的东西更少，因为他们不是在逆流而上，而是在顺流而上，所以作为一个运动的感知度就更低了，因为他们不需要那种意识，因为他们不是局外人。他们是建制派的一部分。
club and all that sort of carry on. I mean, I think it's undeniable that England has an Enlightenment, but because there's less to kick against, because they're not kicking against the grain, because they are going with the grain, there's less of a sense of them as a movement because they don't have to have that sense because they're not outsiders. They're part of the establishment.
但难道不是吗，而且英国人在整个 18 世纪都带着一种极度自以为是的语气这样说，我接下来就要重复这种语气了。是的，说吧。基本上，那种——关键的，你知道，启蒙运动中人们回溯的对象，
But isn't it also, and the English say this throughout the 18th century with a tone of immense smugness, which I'm now going to repeat. Yeah, do. Basically, the kind of the key, you know, the people that people in the Enlightenment look back to,
这绝对包括法国哲学家，伏尔泰首当其冲，他们都在寻找英国 17 世纪的人物。比如培根，弗朗西斯·培根。是的，弗朗西斯·培根和科学方法，完全正确。牛顿。
and this absolutely includes French philosophes, Voltaire preeminently, are looking to figures of the English 17th century. So Bacon, Francis Bacon. Yeah, Francis Bacon and the scientific method, exactly. Newton.
是的，极其重要。洛克。所有这些人，绝对都是 18 世纪思想家顶礼膜拜的庞大人物。还有光荣革命，你可以对此进行辩论。我的意思是，苏格兰和爱尔兰对它有多么光荣的看法是有争议的。但在英格兰，它最终定型并巩固了英国宪法的观念，是的，当然，正如——那种——能够让启蒙运动价值观蓬勃发展的观念，是的，因此 18 世纪启蒙运动至关重要的一部分就是盎格鲁狂热（Anglomania），这是一种将英国视为绝对模范的倾向。我完全同意你的看法，汤姆，我认为——所以如果你看到启蒙运动最伟大的创造之一就是美国宪法
Yeah, massive. Locke. All of them, absolutely massive figures that get enshrined by 18th century thinkers. Well, Shakespeare. Voltaire was obsessed with Shakespeare. Yeah, but Shakespeare's different because Shakespeare is condemned
以及美国共和国本身，那么——那是受到法国思想家孟德斯鸠的思想、三权分立的思想等等的启发的。而他认为那是他从英国、从英国模式中得到的。我的意思是，他错了。他稍微误解了英国模式。但他的盎格鲁狂热正是他随后传播的东西。盎格鲁狂热（Anglomanie）。盎格鲁狂热（Anglomanie）。很好，克卢索探长。
for not obeying the kind of classical regularities. But Bacon, Newton and Locke are all massive, massive figures. And then you have the Glorious Revolution, which you can debate. I mean, the views in Scotland and Ireland on how glorious it is would be contested. But in England, it comes to bed down and it embeds an idea of the english constitution yeah which of course as one as one that yes that that that kind of um enables enlightened values to flourish yeah and and so a crucial part of the 18th century enlightenment is anglomania it's a kind of looking to england as an absolute model i completely agree with you tom i think so if you see one of the great creations of the enlightenment is the american constitution
因为没有遵循那种古典常规。但培根、牛顿和洛克都是非常、非常重要的人物。然后是光荣革命，你可以对此进行争论。我的意思是，苏格兰和爱尔兰对它有多“光荣”的看法会受到质疑。但在英格兰，它最终尘埃落定，并根植了一种英国宪法的理念，是的，当然，这种理念让启蒙价值观得以蓬勃发展，是的，因此十八世纪启蒙运动的一个关键部分就是英国狂热（anglomania），这是一种将英国视为绝对模范的倾向，汤姆，我完全同意你的观点，我认为如果看到启蒙运动伟大的创造之一就是美国宪法
and the the american republic itself then um that is informed by the ideas of the french thinker montesquieu the idea of the separation of powers and so on. And he thought he'd got that from Britain, from the English model. I mean, he was wrong. He slightly misunderstood the English model. But his Anglomania was what he then transported. Anglomanie. Anglomanie. Very good, Inspector Clouseau.
以及美国共和国本身，那么这受到法国思想家孟德斯鸠的思想的影响，比如三权分立等概念。他认为他是从英国、从英国模式中得到这一点的。我的意思是，他弄错了。他稍微误解了英国模式。但他的这种对英国的狂热正是他随后传播开来的。“Anglomanie”（英迷）。“Anglomanie”。很好，克鲁索探长。
Right. I think on that patriotic note, we should go to a break. Should you go and practice your French and then we'll reconvene and shed some more light on the world of darkness and superstition after the break. A bientot. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
好的。我觉得在这个充满爱国主义情怀的时刻，我们应该休息一下。你去练习一下你的法语，休息之后我们再重新开会，为黑暗与迷信的世界带来更多光明。A bientot. 我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history we are talking the enlightenment um and when we left we were being very patriotic dominic so i think we should we should slightly um we should allow the clouds slightly to to blot out the blaze of of the sun and go and begin with a question from native classicist yeah who writes as a native
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及优先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史至上》，我们正在讨论启蒙运动。嗯，刚才离开时我们表现得非常爱国，多米尼克，所以我觉得我们应该稍微……我们应该让乌云稍微遮蔽一下太阳的光芒，从一个本土古典学家的提问开始。是的，他写道：作为一个原住民
american i was only aware of thomas jefferson calling us merciless indian savages listening to gibbons the history of the decline and fall of the roman empire on audiobook he describes countless peoples as savages can you discuss the 18th century european mindset so this feeds in very well to a kind of sense that is also very popular at the present. You know, there are people who enshrine the Enlightenment as absolutely the seedbed of liberalism and everything. But also there are those who argue that it essentially has created all the worst in the modern world, that it's underpinned Western colonialism and racism. Scientific racism. So what's your take on that? It's underpinned Western colonialism and racism. Scientific racism.
美国人，我只知道托马斯·杰斐逊称我们为“无情的印第安野蛮人”。我在有声书里听吉本的《罗马帝国衰亡史》时，他将无数的人群描述为野蛮人。你能讨论一下18世纪欧洲人的心态吗？这很好地契合了当今也非常流行的一种观点。你知道，有些人将启蒙运动奉为自由主义及一切事物的绝对源泉。但也有人认为，它本质上创造了现代世界中最糟糕的一切，它构成了西方殖民主义和种族主义的基础。科学种族主义。那么你对此有何看法？它构成了西方殖民主义和种族主义的基础。科学种族主义。
So what's your take on that? Well, the Enlightenment clearly coincides with the great peak of the slave trade, doesn't it? And there's no doubt that there was always a darker side to the Enlightenment as there was a dark side to all ages. I don't think that necessarily means the Enlightenment is uniquely depraved. But I think it's certainly true that when you think about scientific racism, for example, the idea that the world is divided into different – humanity is divided into different races, some with different achievements, different accomplishments, and so on, that are innate. That obviously is informed by an age that loves to classify
那么你对此有何看法？嗯，启蒙运动显然与奴隶贸易的最高峰同时发生，不是吗？毫无疑问，启蒙运动一直都有黑暗的一面，正如所有时代都有黑暗的一面一样。我不认为这必然意味着启蒙运动是独一无二的堕落。但我认为可以肯定的是，当你想起科学种族主义时，例如，世界被划分为不同的——人类被划分为不同的种族，其中一些种族具有不同的成就、不同的造诣等等，并且这些是天生的。这显然是受到了一个热爱分类的时代的启发。
and loves to divide things up and label them, and is also an age in which a lot of these people and their associates are making tons of money from the triangular trade with the colonists. So I think that side of it is undoubtedly there. And there is undoubtedly, I mean, I'm sure you all have a lot to say about this, that there is this obsession and absolute fascination with the idea of the savage. And you see that in Robinson Crusoe, you see that in Rousseau, the idea of the noble savage, people in a state of nature. And they're absolutely obsessed with this idea, with the tension between civilization and barbarism or savagery. And I think Gibbon writing about all that in The Decline and Fall,
并且热爱将事物划分和贴上标签，这也是一个许多这样的人以及他们的同伙通过与殖民者的三角贸易赚取巨额财富的时代。所以我认为这方面无疑是存在的。毫无疑问，我的意思是，确信你们所有人对此都有很多话要说，那就是对野蛮人这个概念有着这种痴迷和绝对的着迷。你在《鲁滨逊漂流记》中看到了这一点，你在卢梭身上看到了这一点，即高贵野蛮人的概念，处于自然状态的人。他们对这个概念绝对着迷，对文明与野蛮或未化状态之间的张力绝对着迷。我认为吉本在《衰亡史》中对这一切的论述，
that is merely one example of, you know, a huge sort of range of stuff. Yeah, I mean, I think that one of the ways in which, say, Voltaire or Hume, both of whom are some of the more radical enemies of Christianity, one of the ways in which they're able to liberate themselves from the heritage of Christianity is that they the ways in which they're able to liberate themselves from the heritage of Christianity is that they don't feel the need to subscribe to the Genesis story, the idea that all humans have descended from Adam and Eve and therefore have one single source. So Voltaire in particular is a great enthusiast of the idea of polygenesis, the idea that different races have emerged at different points of time. And that that of course i mean he's he's pretty racist he he is able to kind of rank
这仅仅是……你知道的，海量内容中的一个例子。是的，我的意思是，我认为伏尔泰或休谟——这两位都是基督教最激进的敌人中的几个——他们能够让自己从基督教的传统中解放出来的方式之一，就是他们能够让自己从基督教的传统中解放出来的其中一种方式，就是他们觉得没有必要认同创世记的故事，即所有人类都源自亚当和夏娃，因此拥有单一的源头。因此，伏尔泰尤其对多元起源论（即不同的种族在不同的时间点出现）的想法有着极大的热情。这当然——我的意思是，他相当种族主义——他能够将
races according to ability and it seems that hume does the same i mean there's there's this kind of controversy over hume that he's been cancelled yeah he's been cancelled by edinburgh university i mean he was the great you know i mean he's, he's the titanic figure in the Scottish Enlightenment. I mean, what you would say in their defence is they don't know where that racism is going to lead. But at the same time, you would in the case, the prosecutors would say, but they do know that the trade in slaves is going on. Yeah, but so Hume, I mean, Hume is not in favour of the slave trade. And it's unclear why he says, you know, Africans are inferior to white people. And he seems to, I mean, it's unclear why he thinks that.
种族按能力进行等级划分，休谟似乎也做了同样的事情。我的意思是，关于休谟存在着这样一种争议，他被“取消”了。是的，他被爱丁堡大学“取消”了。我的意思是，他曾经是伟大的——你知道的，我的意思是，他是苏格兰启蒙运动中的泰斗级人物。我的意思是，在他们辩护时你会说，他们并不知道那种种族主义将会走向何方。但与此同时，控方会说，但他们确实知道奴隶贸易正在发生。是的，但是休谟——我的意思是，休谟并不赞成奴隶贸易。目前还不清楚为什么他说，你知道，非洲人不如白人。他似乎——我的意思是，目前还不清楚他为什么会这么想。
But he did think that. Yeah. And I think that, you know, I would imagine that what underlies it is, you know, as I say, he doesn't feel any obligation to hold this idea that all human beings are essentially created in the image of God. On the specifics of Native Americans, actually, a lot of the Enlightenment figures are very hostile to European colonialism. They regard it as very pernicious. You have William Robertson, again, one of the great figures of the Scottish Enlightenment, historian who writes History of the Americas. And he brilliantly describes the Aztecs and the Incas as polished nations, which is the highest praise that any figure in the Enlightenment can offer.
但他确实是这么想的。是的。我想，你知道的，我想这背后的基础是——正如我所说，他并不觉得有任何义务去坚持“所有人类本质上都是按上帝的形象创造的”这一观念。具体到美洲原住民，事实上，许多启蒙运动人物对欧洲殖民主义非常敌视。他们认为这是极其有害的。你有威廉·罗伯逊，同样是苏格兰启蒙运动的伟大人物之一，他是一位撰写了《美洲史》的历史学家。他精彩地将阿兹特克人和印加人描述为“受过文明教化的民族”，这是启蒙运动中任何人所能给予的最高赞誉。
You're a polished nation. I mean, that's absolutely the best. And he describes the Native Americans as being like the ancient Britons. So the key there is that he's not in favour of savagery. And Gibbon does the same. I mean, Gibbon has great fun in describing, say, the Scots as being cannibals and utter savages. But he's doing it in the full consciousness that Scotland is now the great centre of enlightenment. So the philosopher, with the exception of Rousseau, tend not to be in favour of people they would describe as savages.
你们是一个受过文明教化的民族。我的意思是，这绝对是最高的评价。他将美洲原住民描述得就像古代不列颠人一样。所以关键在于，他并不赞成野蛮状态。吉本也做了同样的事情。我的意思是，吉本在把苏格兰人描述为食人族和彻头彻尾的野蛮人时觉得非常有趣。但他这样做时，完全意识到苏格兰现在已经是启蒙运动的伟大中心。因此，哲学家们——除了卢梭之外——往往不支持那些他们会称之为野蛮人的人。
But I think most of them see this as part of the kind of the Enlightenment universalism, that everyone can become enlightened. And as examples of that, they would show the development of, say, Britain's from the savagery of the Roman period to the enlightened, polished state of Britain in the 18th century. Yeah. Although this is then quite different, isn't it, from Rousseau? Rousseau deplores what he sees as kind of, what's he called, a civil man or something like that. He thinks very badly of the kind of process of civilisation.
但我认为他们大多数人将这视为启蒙运动普遍主义的一部分，即每个人都可以开化。作为这方面的例子，他们会展示英国人从罗马时期的野蛮状态发展到18世纪英国开明、文明状态的过程。是的。尽管这与卢梭有很大的不同，不是吗？卢梭痛恨他所看到的所谓的——他称之为什么来着？文明人还是类似的东西。他对文明化的过程抱有非常糟糕的看法。
He thinks we should get back to a kind of state of grace that we're born in before civilisation has had its corrupting effect. So he's the man that you associate more than anybody else with the idea of the noble savage, don't you? Well, I mean, that kind of, in one sense, goes back to Locke, who argues that there are no innate ideas, that each human being is a kind of tabula rasa, a blank slate. Locke is also a human rights man, isn't he? The idea of inalienable human rights. But also this is, get ready with your drinking game this is also framed by a kind of christian argument that goes it was going to be cricket i thought it was going to be cricket it wasn't because because there's this argument between augustine and pelagius um at the you know the uh in the um fourth or fifth century about whether are humans fallen?
他认为我们应该回到我们在文明产生其腐蚀作用之前所生来就具备的那种恩典状态。所以比起任何人，他才是你最常与“高贵野蛮人”概念联系在一起的人，不是吗？嗯，我的意思是，某种程度上，这可以追溯到洛克，他认为没有天生观念，每个人都是一种白板（tabula rasa）。洛克也是一个人权主义者，不是吗？不可剥夺的人权的理念。但这也是——准备好你们的喝酒游戏——这也是由一种基督教论点所塑造的——它本来会是板球，我以为会是板球，但不是，因为奥古斯丁和伯拉纠之间有这样一个争论，在公元四世纪或五世纪的时候，关于人类是否是堕落的？
Are they naturally evil? Yeah. Is there a kind of taint of sin or are they naturally good? And Pelagius argues they're naturally good. Augustine argues, no, you know,
他们天生邪恶吗？是的。是否存在某种罪恶的污点，还是他们天生善良？伯拉纠认为他们天生善良。奥古斯丁认为，不，你知道的，
we're all steeped in sin and it's the Augustinian vision that wins out. I think a crucial part of the Enlightenment is a reaction against that and a kind of return to the Pelagian idea
我们都深陷罪恶之中，最终胜出的是奥古斯丁式的愿景。我认为启蒙运动至关重要的一部分是对这种观点的反弹，并某种程度上回归到伯拉纠的思想，
that actually we are naturally good. Yes. So Rousseau famously, man is born free, everywhere is in chains. But you get it with Diderot as well, who argues that humans are not naturally evil, that it's bad education, it's pressures in society, it's evil laws that serve to corrupt us and that's absolutely you know that's clearly a crucial part of what feeds into modern political argument i mean there's a kind of buried argument there between augustine and plagiarism between i guess it would be kind of rousseau and hobbes wouldn't it yeah it is buried there life is nasty brutish and short versus you know let's
即实际上我们天生是善良的。是的。所以伏尔泰（译者注：原文如此）有一句名言：人是生而自由的，却无往不在枷锁之中。你在狄德罗身上也能看到这一点，他认为人类并非天生邪恶，是糟糕的教育、社会压力、邪恶的法律败坏了我们，这绝对是——你知道的，这显然是构成现代政治争论的重要部分——我的意思是，其中潜藏着奥古斯丁主义与伯拉纠主义之间的争论，我想大约就是卢梭与霍布斯之间的争论吧，对吧？是的，它就潜藏在那里：人生而孤独、贫困、卑污、残忍和短寿，对比于（你知道的）让我们
all be kind um but of course famously you would love this russo is an absolute horror he's actually i've actually dug out your diderot said about russo false as vain as satan ungrateful cruel hypocritical and wicked he sucked ideas from me used them himself and then affected to despise me let's hope i never say that about you, Tom. Yeah. It'd be a horror, wouldn't it? So, I mean, by and large, you know, we talked about the philosophical, the Enlightenment figures are fun.
都保持善良吧。但当然，正如你所熟知的，卢梭是个绝对的怪胎。实际上，我甚至把狄德罗对卢梭的评价挖出来了：“虚伪得像撒旦，忘恩负义、残酷、虚伪而邪恶。他从我这里吸取思想，自己使用，然后装作鄙视我。”希望我永远不会对你这么说，汤姆。是的。那将是一场噩梦，不是吗？所以，总的来说，你知道的，我们讨论过，哲学上，启蒙运动的人物很有趣。
I mean, they're kind of entertaining people to be with. Rousseau is not. So he goes to stay with Hume. And Hume is a famously charming man. I mean, he's great company. Everybody loves Hume is a famously charming man. I mean, he's great company. Everybody loves Hume, even people who are shocked by his atheistical views. But Rousseau and Hume, even Hume couldn't get on with Rousseau. But Rousseau is troubled, isn't he?
我的意思是，和他们在一起挺有意思的。卢梭则不然。所以他去和休谟呆在一起。休谟是一个出了名的迷人的人。我的意思是，他是个很好的伴侣。每个人都喜欢休谟——休谟是一个出了名的迷人的人。我的意思是，他是个很好的伴侣。每个人都喜欢休谟，甚至连那些被他的无神论观点震惊的人也喜欢他。但卢梭和休谟，甚至连休谟都无法和卢梭相处。但卢梭很苦恼，不是吗？
Because he has a dreadful problem about going to the toilet. Yes. Did you know this? He has some issue. I did. It's kind of a bit unclear. Is it that he can't go? And he just is storing up vast quantities of urine? And that makes him very uncomfortable.
因为他上厕所有一个可怕的问题。是的。你知道这件事吗？他有什么毛病。我知道。这有点说不清楚。是因为他拉不出来吗？他只是在体内储存大量的尿液？这让他很不舒服。
And so he doesn't go out or something. Is that what it is? Well, what I do know is that Boswell, the biographer of Dr. Johnson, he goes on a tour and he goes to visit Rousseau. And Rousseau is always trying to get away from him by going on the toilet. Right. And Boswell follows him into by going on the toilet. Right. And, and Boswell follows him into the toilet on several occasions. And what happens? What's going on in there?
所以他不出门或者类似的原因？是这样吗？嗯，我所知道的是，约翰逊博士的传记作者鲍斯韦尔去旅行并拜访了卢梭。卢梭总是试图通过上厕所来避开他。对的。而鲍斯韦尔好几次跟着他进了——通过上厕所。对的，而且，鲍斯韦尔好几次跟着他进了洗手间。结果怎么样？里面发生了什么？
Exactly. What's happening? Yeah. Also Diderot. Do you know, um, what Diderot blamed the greatest cause of flatulence on? Rousseau?
到底怎么回事？发生了什么？是的。还有狄德罗。你知道，嗯，狄德罗把导致肠胃气胀（放屁）的最大原因归咎于什么吗？卢梭？
The potato. Really? Yeah. Well, the potato, I suppose it was a relative novelty. relative novelty um uh probably say he was not a fish and chips man clearly no no absolutely not um anyway listen uh we mustn't get into let's do some questions let's do um so let's do jeff jeff let's do jeff and caffeine jeff says what's
马铃薯。真的吗？是的。嗯，马铃薯，我猜那是个相对新鲜的事物。相对新鲜的事物，嗯，大概可以说他显然不是个爱吃炸鱼薯条的人。不，不，绝对不是。无论如何，听着，我们绝不能陷入——我们来做几个问题吧，我们来做——所以我们来做杰夫的，杰夫，我们来做杰夫和咖啡因。杰夫说，
the role of caffeine in the era's narrative do you want to answer that tom what Tom? What is the role of caffeine? No, I think you should answer that. That's very much you. I think it's very important. And I think, actually, if you put England back into the story, England and Holland, I suppose, back into the story of the Enlightenment, from which they're often left out, then caffeine looms very large. Because, of course, coffeehouses are one of the paradigmatic public spaces where people are getting information, reading newspapers, they're swapping ideas.
咖啡因在这个时代的叙事中扮演什么角色？你想回答那个问题吗，汤姆？汤姆，咖啡因扮演什么角色？不，我觉得你应该回答。这非常符合你的风格。我认为这非常重要。事实上，如果你把英格兰重新放回这个故事中，英格兰和荷兰，我猜，放回启蒙运动的故事中——它们经常被排除在外——那么咖啡因就显得非常重要了。因为当然，咖啡馆是人们获取信息、阅读报纸、交流思想的典范公共空间之一。
So caffeine absolutely matters. And I think particularly in England. I think in Scotland, it's the universities that are the powerhouses of the Enlightenment. And I think in France, it's the court, particularly the court of Frederick the Great, where Volta goes. And then they have Spadaglia bust up and he has to leave
所以咖啡因绝对重要。我认为尤其是在英格兰。我认为在苏格兰，大学是启蒙运动的动力室。我认为在法国，是宫廷，特别是伏尔泰去过的腓特烈大帝的宫廷。然后他们大吵了一架，他不得不离开。
so I think it's courts universities and coffee houses and they're different in each country I think that's absolutely right so Gordon Smith asked about Scotland the Scottish Enlightenment where does it come from
所以我认为是宫廷、大学和咖啡馆，在每个国家都各不相同。我认为这绝对正确。所以戈登··史密斯询问关于苏格兰、苏格兰启蒙运动的问题：它从何而来？
why does it come from such a small country you've kind of answered that haven't Why does it come from such a small country? You've kind of answered that, haven't you, Tom? I mean, Scotland is a small country, but it's also part of a much bigger enterprise at this point. So Scotland and the cities are enjoying massive economic growth. But as you said, the universities are absolutely crucial to the Scottish Enlightenment, aren't they? Yeah, unlike England, where we only have Oxford and Cambridge, which are at their most kind of port-soaked. Yes, that's true.
为什么它会诞生于这样一个弹丸小国？你差不多已经回答了这个问题，不是吗，汤姆？为什么它会诞生于这样一个弹丸小国？你差不多已经回答了这个问题，不是吗，汤姆？我的意思是，苏格兰是一个小国，但它在此时也是一个更宏大事业的一部分。所以苏格兰和它的城市正享受着巨大的经济增长。但正如你所说，大学对苏格兰启蒙运动绝对至关重要，对吧？是的，不像英格兰，我们只有牛津和剑桥，它们正处于最沉溺于波特酒的状态。是的，这倒真的。
Yeah. That's just sort of old clergymen contemplating the meaninglessness of life. Snuff-stained waistcoats. Dusty wigs. Yeah. Okay. Brilliant. So we've solved the causes of Scottish Enlightenment there.
是的。那只是一群老牧师在沉思生命的无意义。沾满鼻烟的背心。落满灰尘的假发。好的。太棒了。所以我们已经解开了苏格兰启蒙运动起因之谜。
Pat Roberts. Pat Roberts. Is it possible to have a the causes of Scottish Enlightenment there. Pat Roberts. Pat Roberts. Is it possible to have a good drama about the Enlightenment when compared with Tudors and Nazis, it's just blokes in a room writing books? Well, that's a very glamorous pastime, I would say. E.G. Pat Roberts mentions Amadeus, Barry Lyndon, The Great on TV, a royal affair about Enlightened absolutism in Denmark.
帕特·罗伯茨。帕特·罗伯茨。围绕启蒙运动制作一部优秀的剧集可能吗？相比于都铎王朝和纳粹，它不过是一群家伙在房间里写书？嗯，这是一种非常迷人的消遣，我得说。比如帕特·罗伯茨提到的《莫扎特传》、《巴里·林顿》、电视上的《凯瑟琳大帝》——一部关于丹麦开明专制的皇室风流史。
I'm not aware of that series or film or whatever but um could you have a the great have you seen the great no it's catherine the great catherine the great is it good is it great i think it's hilarious i mean it has absolutely tangential relationship to right i mean it's more like black adder than it is okay barry linden but it's very funny there was a very funny episode where, was it actually Voltaire? Completely ahistorically turns up and is Catherine the Great is all over him and decides he's very boring. And sends him away.
我不知道那个剧集还是电影或者什么的，但是，你能拍一部——《凯瑟琳大帝》，你看过《凯瑟琳大帝》吗？没有。那是叶卡捷琳娜大帝。叶卡捷琳娜大帝。好看吗？棒吗？我觉得滑稽极了。我的意思是，它与真实的——我的意思是，它与历史的关系非常边缘，对吧？我的意思是，它比起《巴里·林顿》更像是《黑爵士》，但非常搞笑。有一个非常搞笑的桥段——是伏尔泰吗？完全不顾历史事实地出现了，叶卡捷琳娜大帝对他崇拜得不得了，结果发现他极其无聊。然后把他打发走了。
Yeah. Is he played by a comedy Frenchman? I can't remember. I'd love if they got Gérard Depardieu to play him. He's too large. Yeah, but that would be the joke there, wouldn't it? He'd be completely wrong. What about John Adams?
是的。他是被一个搞笑的法国演员扮演的吗？我不记得了。如果他们能请来杰拉尔·德帕迪约来演他，我可太喜欢了。他太胖了。对，但那不就是笑点所在吗？他会完全不对路。那《约翰·亚当斯》呢？
Have you seen John Adams? That's a brilliant series and very enlightened. I mean, he's a very enlightened figure, as are Jefferson and Franklin and all the other people that crop up in the series. Have you seen that, Tom? No, I haven't. Paul Giamatti is John Adams, and he's very good.
你看过《约翰·亚当斯》吗？那是一部极其精彩的剧集，也非常开明。我的意思是，他是一个非常开明的人物，杰斐逊和富兰克林以及剧中出现的其他人也是如此。你看过那个吗，汤姆？没有，我没看过。保罗·吉亚玛提饰演约翰·亚当斯，他演得非常好。
But if you haven't seen it, there's no point talking about it. But what I would like to say about, about Franklin, inventor of the lightning rod. Yeah. But there was another inventor of the lightning rod. He was a Czech Catholic priest. Was there? So Benjamin Franklin has,
但如果你没看过，讨论它就没有任何意义了。不过我想说的是，关于富兰克林，避雷针的发明者。是的。但还有另一个避雷针的发明者。他是一名捷克天主教神父。是吗？所以本杰明·富兰克林——
he's done a bit of a Russo. He's stolen, he's sucked. No, he hasn't stolen it, but, but, but it's kind of interesting that,
他有点像卢梭。他偷窃了，他吸取了——不，他没有偷窃，但是，但是，但是挺有趣的，
that one of them, you know, is enshrined as a, yes, of course it's kind of interesting that one of them you know is enshrined as a yes of course a kind of model of progress whereas the fact
他们中的一个人（你知道的）被奉为——是的，当然，挺有趣的，他们中的一个人（你知道的）被奉为——是的，当然，作为进步的典范，
that there was a Czech Catholic priest is slightly buried okay yeah well that I mean the faith generally gets
而事实上存在过一位捷克天主教神父这件事却被稍微掩盖了。好吧，是的，我的意思是——信仰通常被——
written out of this I mean I don't want to set you set you off again but you will set me off but faith generally gets written out
被从这段历史中抹去。我的意思是，我不想再次惹恼你，但你确实会惹恼我——但信仰通常被从这个故事中抹去，
of this story doesn't it because a lot of these people are fascinated by religion. Some of them are very religious themselves. Most of them are.
不是吗？因为这些人中的许多人对宗教着迷。他们中的一些人本身就非常虔诚。大多数人都是。
I mean, the atheists are an absolute minority. But that kind of gets suppressed. So what people now do is talk about atheists and deism and that other side of things. Well, deism, by definition, isn't atheism. Yeah, of course. Of course. Okay, how about Lloyd? Now, Lloyd asks what I would call the John Gray question. Brilliant thinker, John Gray, essayist for the New Statesman. He says, while Western liberalism is often described as part of an enlightenment project, how much can we say that the competitor ideologies of communism or fascism are also enlightenment projects and of course the thinker john gray would say they absolutely are they are the they are the kind of logical development of enlightenment ideas about
我的意思是，无神论者绝对是少数。但这被压制了。所以现在人们做的是谈论无神论者和自然神论以及事情的另一面。嗯，自然神论，按定义来说，就不是无神论。是的，当然。当然。好吧，劳埃德怎么样？现在，劳埃德问了一个我会称之为“约翰·格雷问题”的问题。才华横溢的思想家约翰·格雷，《新政治家》杂志的撰稿人。他说，虽然西方 liberalism（自由主义）通常被描述为启蒙运动项目的一部分，但我们可以说，共产主义或法西斯主义等竞争意识形态在多大程度上也是启蒙运动项目呢？当然，思想家约翰·格雷会说它们绝对是。它们是——它们是启蒙运动关于理性的思想的逻辑发展，
reason and the general will and these kinds of things so what do you think about communism and fascism tom enlightenment well you know because we've done we've done episodes on them yeah so and you know that i you i would trace its origins much further back than the enlightenment would you i would say there are enlightenment certainly. Certainly communism is an Enlightenment project, isn't it? Post-Enlightenment project? It's a post-Christian project. Post-Christian, of course. That's another drink on.
还有总意志以及诸如此类的东西。所以你对共产主义和法西斯主义怎么看，汤姆？启蒙运动？嗯，你知道的，因为我们做过——我们做过关于它们的单集。是的，所以，你知道的——我会把它们的起源追溯到比启蒙运动更早得多的时期，会吗？我会说它们是启蒙运动的产物——当然。共产主义当然是启蒙运动的项目，对吧？后启蒙运动项目？这是一个后基督教项目。后基督教，当然。这又是宾果卡片上的一个勾。
That's another tick on the bingo card. And talking of which, Diogo Morgado, does the Muslim world need a kind of Enlightenment today? The power of the religion in everyday life is staggering, something that isn't seen in the West. I think you should answer that question. Okay, I think that's a really interesting question. We're planning to do an episode on Napoleon in Egypt, which is really, I mean, it's a fascinating episode
说到这里，迪奥戈·莫尔加多问：当今的穆斯林世界是否需要某种启蒙运动？宗教在日常生活中的力量令人震惊，这是西方所看不到的。我觉得你应该回答这个问题。好的，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题。我们正计划做一个关于拿破仑在埃及的单集，这真的——我的意思是，这是一个引人入胜的单集，
because you talked about Napoleon as an enlightenment despot. It's the first meeting between the Enlightenment and the world of Islam. What I think that question highlights, and I think that the episode of Napoleon in Egypt definitely does, is the degree to which, as I've been saying throughout, the Enlightenment is a very culturally contingent phenomenon. It's rooted in the specifics of Western Europe and specifically in deeply rooted Christian assumptions. And it's when it comes up against, say, a civilization as rich and complex and ancient as the Muslim world that you come to recognize that. And today you see that people often talk about the enlightenment values in the context of Islam.
因为你把拿破仑称为开明专制君主。这是启蒙运动与伊斯兰世界的第一次相遇。我认为那个问题突显出的是，并且拿破仑在埃及那一集也绝对突显出的是，正如我通篇所说的那样，启蒙运动在很大程度上是一个受文化制约的现象。它扎根于西欧的具体特性中，特别是扎根于根深蒂固的基督教假设中。正当它与像穆斯林世界这样丰富、复杂且古老的文明碰撞时，你才会认识到这一点。今天你可以看到人们经常在伊斯兰教的背景下谈论启蒙运动的价值观。
They say, I'm a defender of the enlightened values and that therefore entitles me to do draw cartoons of Mohammed or whatever, or pose the veil or something like that. And it highlights the way in which the enlightenment like islam and like the christianity that it emerges from is universalist in its scope yeah of course it is people talk about exporting enlightenment values don't they absolutely and so that thing that i said you know where voltaire is sneering at the church fathers because they want to convert the whole world to their way of thinking
他们说，我是启蒙价值观的捍卫者，因此这赋予了我画穆罕默德漫画或做诸如此类事情的权利，或者反对面纱之类的。它凸显了这样一种方式：启蒙运动就像伊斯兰教以及它所脱胎而出的基督教一样，在其视野上是普遍主义的。是的，当然是的。人们谈论输出启蒙价值观，不是吗？绝对的。所以，我刚才说的那种伏尔泰嘲笑教会之父的情况，因为他们想把全世界都皈依到他们的思考方式上，
that's exactly what the enlightenment is is all about. And so therefore, what do you do with something like Islam that is similarly universalist, similarly rich and complex? It's very indigestible. And really, if you're an Enlightener, if you're an enthusiast for the Enlightenment, then of course you think that the world should should should have an enlightenment in exactly the same way that if you're a de facto christian you think that muslims should become christian or indeed if you're a muslim you think that that the rest of the world should become muslim it's it's and you know we we still live in the 21st century in this kind of tension between the rival universalisms of what we could used to call christendom and the Muslim world. Yeah, I pretty much agree with that, Tom.
这正是启蒙运动的全部意义所在。因此，面对像伊斯兰教这样同样具有普遍主义、同样丰富而复杂的文明，你该怎么办？这非常难以消化。老实说，如果你是一个启蒙主义者，如果你是启蒙运动的热心支持者，那么你当然会认为世界应该——应该——应该经历一场启蒙运动，这就像如果你实际上是个基督教徒，你就会认为穆斯林应该成为基督教徒，或者如果你是个穆斯林，你就会认为世界上其余地方都应该成为穆斯林一样。这——你知道的，我们依然生活在21世纪，夹在曾经被称为基督教世界和穆斯林世界的这两个相互竞争的普遍主义之间的这种张力中。是的，汤姆，我基本上同意这一点。
I think the key thing is defenders of the self-declared enthusiasts for the Enlightenment often don't accept and don't see what I think you rightly say, that the Enlightenment is itself culturally contingent, that it comes out of a particular world at a particular place in time, and that its claims to universal human values are themselves rooted in something. And to me, it's as though they can't see that that is itself, you know, a universalizing project, just as you say.
我认为关键在于，自我宣称的启蒙运动热心支持者们往往不接受也看不清我所认为你正确指出的那一点，即启蒙运动本身是受文化制约的，它诞生于特定时空的特定世界，它对普遍人类价值的主张本身就根植于某些东西。对我而言，这就好像他们看不到这本身——你知道的——就是一个追求普遍化的项目，正如你所说的那样。
You know, that sort of thing of like, let's go to Afghanistan, let's go to Iraq with our copies of Candide. Yes. And we're doing it in the name of universal human rights. Yeah. I sort of think, why can't you see why to them, to the people you're claiming for China, which he sees as a kind of enlightened despotism that should be a model for Europeans and doesn't have Christianity and therefore is highly to be applauded. But he knows nothing about China whatsoever. And then he meets with a Jesuit who's been in China, who's been at the imperial court and corrects him on his, you know, misapprehensions.
你知道，那种感觉就像：让我们带着《老实人》的副本来到阿富汗，来到伊拉克。是的。我们是以普遍人权的名义这样做的。是的。我心里想，为什么你们就不能理解，为什么在他们——也就是你们声称要为其……（比如伏尔泰）对中国推崇备至，他将中国视为一种开明专制，认为这应该成为欧洲人的榜样，而且中国没有基督教，因此大受赞赏。但他对中国一无所得。然后他遇到了一个去过中国、去过帝国宫廷的耶稣会士，对方纠正了他那些（你知道的）误解。
So Volta volta has a massive strop about this and starts trying the india as the model of it that's funny has he been to india no of course no no there's nothing about it no there's nothing about it at all so he's basically volta volta is a great enthusiast for rejecting his idea of what of how a state should be organized you know in china or india or whatever uh's funny. I think we have we sort of we done the Enlightenment now? There's one more question, which somebody asked online. I've forgotten who it is. I'm terribly sorry if this is your question, but I thought it was fascinating about Freemasonry and about Freemasonry and the Enlightenment.
所以伏尔泰为此大发雷霆，并开始试图把印度当作榜样。这真搞笑，他去过印度吗？没有，当然没有，完全没有。所以基本上，伏尔泰是一个极力热衷于拒绝他自己对国家组织方式想象的人（无论是在中国、印度还是其他地方）。这真搞笑。我想我们——我们现在讨论完启蒙运动了吗？还有一个问题，有人在线上提问。我忘了是谁了。如果这是你的问题，我深表歉意，但我认为关于共济会以及共济会与启蒙运动的那部分非常迷人。
And so many of these people were Freemasons. Voltaire was a Freemason. Montesquieu was a Freemason. Diderot, Goethe, Mozart, Benjamin Franklin, who you talked about, was a very were Freemasons. Voltaire was a Freemason. Montesquieu was a Freemason. Diderot, Goethe, Mozart. Benjamin Franklin, who you talked about, was a very keen Freemason. And, of course, Masonic imagery appears on the dollar and in sort of the American Republican, the iconography of the American Republic.
其中有这么多人都是共济会员。伏尔泰是共济会员。孟德斯鸠是共济会员。狄德罗、歌德、莫扎特，你刚才提到的本杰明·富兰克林，都是极其狂热的共济会员。伏尔泰是共济会员。孟德斯鸠是共济会员。狄德罗、歌德、莫扎特。你刚才提到的本杰明·富兰克林是一个非常狂热的共济会员。当然，共济会的意象出现在美元上，以及某种程度上美国共和政体的肖像学中。
And I think Freemasonry was absolutely central to the Enlightenment. I mean, a Masonic lodge was like the sort of Soho house, the trendy private members club of the Enlightened world. So Masonic lodges would be established all over Europe. And again, it's something that starts in Scotland and in England, which sort of reinforces that point that we always think of the Enlightenment as continental, but that all these people basically belong to Anglo-Scottscottish clubs which are their masonic lodges so are you basically saying the enlightenment is essentially british it's british british masonic conspiracy
我认为共济会是启蒙运动的绝对核心。我的意思是，共济会会所就像是启蒙世界的Soho House（苏豪之家），即时髦的私人会员俱乐部。因此，共济会会所在整个欧洲建立起来。同样，这也是一个始于苏格兰和英格兰的事物，这强化了我们之前的观点：我们总是认为启蒙运动是欧洲大陆的产物，但实际上所有这些人基本上都属于英苏俱乐部，也就是他们的共济会会所。所以你基本上是在说，启蒙运动本质上是英国的吗？这是一个英国-英国的共济会阴谋？
i think that's what i'm that's what i'm basically saying um no i think it is i think it's a patriotic note on which to end it is neat but i tell you what we should do though tom which we haven't done which we said we would do who's your favorite and least favorite enlightened enlightenment thinkers um i'm very fond of diderot what because you like encyclopedias he was he was a very kind brilliant generous man um i i think the the scale of his his kind of intellectual inquiries is just phenomenal. I think he kind of is a contradiction to the idea that the Enlightenment was just about classifying and splitting and dividing. He was fascinated by the gaps, by the kind of areas where things didn't quite fit.
我想我基本上就是在说这个。不，我觉得是——我认为这是一个适合作为结尾的爱国主义时刻。这很巧妙。不过我跟你说，汤姆，我们还有一件事没做，我们说过要做的：你最喜欢和最讨厌的启蒙运动思想家分别是谁？我很喜欢狄德罗。为什么？因为你喜欢百科全书？他是一个非常善良、才华横溢、慷慨大度的人。我认为他那种知识探索的规模简直是现象级的。我认为他某种程度上反驳了“启蒙运动只关乎分类、拆分和划分”的观点。他对外在的空白、事物并非完全契合的领域着迷。
So he's very, very sophisticated. And he was very fond of beavers. The furry kind. And he was reduced to tears by the way that the beavers were being wiped out by trappers in North America. And he said, how can people persecute this gentle, appealing, pitiable animal?
所以他非常、非常成熟。而且他非常喜欢海狸。那种毛茸茸的动物。当他看到北美的捕兽人赶尽杀绝海狸时，他甚至伤心得流泪。他说：“人们怎么能迫害这种温柔、可爱、令人怜悯的动物呢？”
And I think that's the Enlightenment at its absolute best. Well, I can't improve on that, actually. I'm just not going to say anything. Okay. Well, you can come in with your worst. Who's your... Oh, my worst is Rousseau. Obviously, I think Rousseau is a terrible man. I mean,
我认为这就是处于绝对最佳状态的启蒙运动。好吧，我无法在此基础上做得更好了，实际上我什么也不说了。好吧，你可以说说你最讨厌的。谁是你的……噢，我最讨厌的是卢梭。显然，我认为卢梭是个糟糕透顶的人。我的意思是，
we've sort of advertised how bad Rousseau was. Edmund Burke. I didn't mention Edmund Burke on Rousseau, but obviously a great... I think a great product in the Enlightenment. One of my favourite Enlightenment thinkers. Burke said of Rousseau, he entertained no principle but vanity with this vice he was possessed to a degree little short of madness.
我们之前已经把卢梭有多糟糕宣传过了。埃德蒙·伯克——我没提到埃德蒙·伯克对卢梭的评价，但显然这是一位伟大的——我认为他是启蒙运动的伟大产物，我最喜欢的启蒙运动思想家之一。伯克这样评价卢梭：“他心中除了虚荣别无原则，他被这种恶习支配的程度几乎达到了疯狂的地步。”
And obviously, you know, Rousseau slightly... If I was Rousseau, I would be looking at the French Revolution and thinking, you know, it doesn't look great for me, my reputation. You know, where did I go wrong? But of course, Rousseau was so vain that he would never have done that. He was a terrible father as well, wasn't he? Yeah, I mean, he's just a terrible man. That business about separating kids from their parents and educating them and you know all that stuff
显然，你知道的，卢梭稍微——如果我是卢梭，我会看着法国大革命然后心想，你知道的，这对我、对我的名声可不太妙。你知道，我在哪里做错了？但当然，卢梭是如此虚荣，他永远不会那样做。他也是个糟糕的父亲，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，他就是个糟糕透顶的人。把孩子和父母分离并教育他们诸如此类的事情——
he's very much the kind of the ancestor of the um the kind of person on twitter who says be kind be kind and then you've found that they're behaving appallingly yeah they say be kind and then you find they've written to your employer to get you sacked. That's exactly who Rousseau is. I can think of so many real current 21st century Rousseaus, but I'm not going to name them because I don't want to end up in a libel court. And so on that note, I think we really should end.
他非常像是那种在推特上说“要善良，要善良”，然后你发现他们行为极其恶劣的人的祖先。是的，他们嘴里喊着“要善良”，然后你发现他们写信给你的雇主好把你开除。这正是卢梭式的人物。我能想到当今21世纪有那么多的卢梭，但我不会点名，因为我不想最后吃官司。所以，基于此，我觉得我们真的该结束了。
Don't you, Tom? Yeah. I think we've brought enormous light to this murky topic and nobody ever need talk about the enlightenment again, because we've done it. Nature and nature's laws lay hidden night. God said that the rest is history be and always light. Bye-bye.
你不这么觉得吗，汤姆？是的。我觉得我们为这个晦涩的话题带来了巨大的光明，从此再也没有人需要讨论启蒙运动了，因为已经被我们讲透了。自然与自然规律隐匿于黑夜，上帝说：“让《历史至上》诞生吧”，于是便有了永恒的光明。拜拜。
Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史至上》。想要获取额外单集、优先收听权、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。